le 17 novembre 2010 8 partout en france
on pouvait croiser des gens vêtus du
gilet fluo obligatoire pour les
automobilistes sur les ronds points les
péages ou simplement il le laissait en
évidence sur le tableau de bord de leur
véhicule en guise de soutien à un
mouvement né sur les réseaux sociaux
motif de la grogne dénoncé la vie trop
chère et demandé plus de considération
de la part d'une classe politique et
médiatique centré sur la vie urbaine
parfois méprisante et déconnecté des
problèmes des français vivant dans les
zones périphériques annoncé en septembre
2018 l'augmentation de la fiscalité sur
le carburant a mis le feu aux poudres
sur le net d'illustrés inconnus se
démarque alors par l'immense audience de
leurs protestations on est traqué on
monte dans notre voiture de toute façon
on est considéré comme quelqu'un qui va
potentiellement payer mais qu'est ce que
vous faites du pognon des français après
l'acte 1 du mouvement un sondage révèle
que 77 % des français estiment que les
revendications des gilet jaune sont
justifiées le samedi suivant les
champs-elysées sont envahis par les
manifestants et des heurts violents avec
les forces de l'ordre se font constater
dès lors plus personne ne semble capable
de cerner ces français qui n'accepte ni
chef ni parti politique ni syndicats à
leur tête discret dans les premiers
temps emmanuel macron s'exprime le 27
novembre et dit comprendre la colère des
manifestants tout en condamnant ces
affrontements ce sera sa ligne pour tout
le reste de la crise mais le mouvement a
démarré et l'acte iii sera la journée de
mobilisation la plus violente du
mouvement à marseille une femme de 80
ans siné bray douane est touché par une
grenade de police alors qu'elle se
trouve à sa fenêtre et elle décédera à
l'hôpital le lendemain après la
dénonciation des taxes sur le carburant
que le gouvernement s'empresse de
suspendre pour six mois ce sont
désormais les violences policières qui
s'invite dans le débat public les
visages des blessés par les armes des
forces de l'ordre défilent sur les
réseaux sociaux il suscite des réactions
y compris à l'international nous
encourageons le gouvernement français à
poursuivre le dialogue et demandons
urgemment une enquête approfondie sur
tous les cas rapportés d'usagé excessif
de la force je voudrais rappeler à tout
le monde qu'en france nous sommes un
état de droit que quand il y à une
plainte elle est instruite et qu'il
faudra probablement expliqué à madame le
commissaire de l'onu l'ensemble des
faits et notamment l'extrême violence
qui s'est déchaînée sur les forces de
l'ordre pardon de le dire comme ça mais
on n'a pas attendu le haut commissaire
de l'onu pour faire toute la lumière sur
l'ensemble des faits dès lors qu'il y à
des plaintes et dès lors que nous
considérons qu'il faut évidemment faire
la lumière et faire toute la
transparence sur l'ensemble des faits
avec le temps le gilet jaune n'a jamais
été définitivement abandonnée des
manifestations le mouvement a eu des
hauts et des bas des morts et des
renaissances régulière et en ces temps
d'inflation et d'envol des prix du
carburant les gilet jaune pourrait de
nouveau s'inviter dans la campagne pour
les présidentielles